I'm very glad to be joined this morning
by the government's chief medical
officer and chief scientific advisor
today we've published the coronavirus
action plan setting out how all four
parts of the UK will take all necessary
and reasonable steps to prepare for and
tackle this outbreak and the plan has
four strands containing the virus
delaying its spread researching its
origins and cure and finally mitigating
the impact should the virus become more
widespread that is contained delay
research mitigate and let me be
absolutely clear that for the
overwhelming majority of people who
contract the virus this will be a mild
disease from which they will speedily
and fully recover as we've already seen
but I fully understand public concern
now your concern about the global spread
of the virus and it is highly likely
that we will see a growing number of UK
cases and that's why keeping the country
safe is the government's overriding
priority and our plan means we're
committed to doing everything possible
based on the advice of our world-leading
scientific experts to prepare for all
eventualities and let's not forget we
already have a fantastic NHS fantastic
testing systems and fantastic
surveillance of the spread of the
disease
we will make sure the NHS gets all the
support it needs to continue their
brilliant response to the virus so far
the plan does not set out what the
government will do it sets out the steps
that we could take at the right time and
on the basis of the scientific advice
our country remains extremely well
prepared
as it has been since the outbreak began
in whoo-ha and several months ago
finally crucially we must not forget
what we can all do to fight this virus
which is to wash our hands in you I was
going to say this but wash our hands
with soap and water and forgive me for
repeating this but there will be people
first tuning into this for the first
time wash your hands with soap and hot
water for the length of time it takes to
sing happy birthday twice
it's simple advice but it's a single
most important thing we can do is I
think our experts would attest but at
this stage and with the exception of all
the points that I have just mentioned I
want to stress that for the vast
majority of the people of this country
we should be going about our business as
usual and on that note I will hand over
to all of you to ask questions to the
chief medical officer and the chief
scientific adviser and I'm going to go
to you guys in the media and Laura
Kingsburg from the BBC and thank you
very much prime minister and first of
all prime minister are you telling
people today that sooner or later all of
our lives are going to be disrupted
somehow and a question to the chief
medical officer and the chief scientific
advisor if I may do you believe at some
point this virus will be bigger than any
effort the government can make to try to
contain it and to the chief medical
officer what is your best guess if you
can of how many people will actually get
this disease even bearing in mind that
the made for the majority of people it's
mild and won't do any long-term harm
what well Laura I think the answer to
your question is I'm afraid at this
stage it is just if I think too too
early to say but I'll hand over to
there's a key point about timing here
and there are a number of measures that
could be taken to try and reduce the
peak and flatten it a bit so we haven't
got such a sharp number of people at any
one time and the question is
at what time to implement which measures
if you do it too early you end up with a
lot of people having disruption a lot of
societal disruption at a time you're not
getting benefit and you also ask a lots
of people to go on for a long time doing
this whereas what we really want to do
is to implement the whatever is
necessary at the time depending on how
the epidemic goes at the right time over
a 12 week period or so is probably
what's going to be needed to do it so we
want to go too early and those measures
of course are the ones that are laid out
in the document it doesn't mean all of
those need to happen it depends on the
nature of the outbreak we're modeling
all of the interventions at the moment
and trying to look at what the right
combination is at what stage and of
course central to all of this is making
sure that we protect the vulnerable and
the highest risk groups are the elderly
and those with pre-existing illness and
those are the ones we've got to make
most most care to protect during this
and as the prime minister says the vast
majority of people will end up with a
mild illness so the timing is critical
and it's not now and we're looking very
carefully at when the time is right and
what the combination of things are that
are going to make the biggest difference
so just to add on from that I mean the
first thing is you asked me specifically
about the best guess on numbers there
are certain things we know now and I
think we're reasonably confident that
overall probably around 1 percent of
people who get this virus might end up
dying based on the Chinese experience
now to be clear what that therefore
means is 99 percent of people will not
and if as I think is entirely possible a
higher proportion than we currently are
aware of get the infection without any
symptoms in fact that mortality rate
will go down but let's take 1% overall
as the current reasonable figure it goes
up a bit in people who are older or more
vulnerable as sir patrick said it will
be much lower than that in pea in
younger people who actually
no other health problems so that bit of
the information we know for sure the bit
of information that we don't know there
are two bits that are critical the
proportion of people who have no
symptoms at all and that's because we
don't currently have tests which can
work out if someone has had an infection
with no symptoms at all so it may be for
example in China a very large number of
people have been infected with no
symptoms and are not being counted in
the numbers so we don't we don't know
that and the second thing we cannot be
sure of is what proportion of the
population can get infected now it will
not go above 80% so for planning
purposes of course we go up to the
highest rate that it reasonably could
but in reality my view and Patricks view
that the the proportion of the
population you get infected is likely to
be lower than that and probably a lot
lower than that so I think putting an
overall number is is largely speculative
but those are I think the key things is
people it's important for people to
understand it's clearly not 80 percent
of the population that's infected with a
one percent mortality rate and so we can
learn from that that this is likely to
be lower than that of course things
could still change moving on and that
could turn out to be different as they
release some of the containment measures
but it's definitely a lot lower than
that and so I think we're what we're
doing is building on the reasonable
worst-case scenario which is the one
that Chris's laid out for planning
purposes which is the appropriate thing
to do and then looking very carefully at
how this evolves what the numbers might
turn out to be couple of questions the
action plan we published today says
there's a possibility that a fifth of
working people will be off work during
the peak period prime minister what will
you do to make sure that those who are
ill don't also suffer hardship
particularly those on low pay and
secondly we're still in the containment
phase what would we have to
here to move into the phase of simply
delaying an epidemic well thanks Robert
on the issue of statutory sick pay and
the risks that the workforce could
conceivably run in that in that worst
case reasonable worst case scenario that
you described we're going to keep all
options under review but we're well
aware of the the issue in terms of
moving from containment to delay the
first point to make is that most of the
things that we do to try and help
contain the virus like finding the early
cases and isolating them also are very
important for delay so they serve both
purposes there will come a point
potentially and not definitely but there
will come a point potentially where the
amount of transmission either in the UK
or equally likely everywhere in the
world is so great that actually the idea
of containing which is to say
essentially getting rid of this virus
completely ceases to make sense we have
not reached that point that we could
reach that point and at that point we
will move over to saying well that fit
is stopped but to be clear many of the
things we're currently doing will
continue because they also have a role
in delay which is as Chris price says
this is an international call of when it
moves from contained today but it's
possible you know when we reach a stage
that we think we can't contain here
other countries do it that we might as a
group of countries decide to do
something so those are the two areas
that we need to keep an eye on thank you
a couple of questions if I may yesterday
the Scottish chief medical officer said
that up to 4% of the population might
have to be hospitalized do you accept
that figure and if so how will the NHS
NHS cope nearly 3 million people being
hospitalized and just a question for the
prime minister as Robert was saying one
in five workers could be off work your
document says in worst case scenario the
police might have to be redeployed just
to deal with serious
crime and maintain public order will you
draft in the army if necessary and can
you promise citizens that in the midst
of all this you can keep them safe thank
you yes thanks very much
I mean deal with it with both those
important points on on the NHS and the
potential pressure on on the NHS you
know I think you have a fantastic health
service and it's well capable of
handling the most tremendous pressures
as it as everybody knows I think one
thing it is it will be important for us
all to to do if it moves in if the virus
moves in to the kind of stages that that
our scientific advisors have just been
talking about it will be very important
for everybody to think not only what we
can do to prevent the spread of the
virus individually but also what we can
do to avoid too much pressure on the NHS
so when it comes to using services such
as GPS or one one one if and it will be
quite important to be self restraining
where we're possible cuz I'd say most
people will unquestionably get through
it and on your on your second point
about the police and the army in bat
there are long-established plans by
which the police will obviously they
will keep the public safe where they
will prioritize those things that they
they have to do and the army is of
course always ready to to backfill as
and when but that is under the the
reasonable worst-case scenario Andy Bell
Sky News that's right five years
idabelle five news um just to return to
the idea of pressures on the NHS there I
mean people will struggle to believe
that the NHS will be able to cope
seamlessly when we all know the
pressures its system is under can you
give us an idea of what will not happen
in the NHS what operations will not
happen for instance what treatments will
not happen if we move the stage where
you could potentially have tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people having to be treated in hospital
so we are one of the reasons that we are
so keen to delay is we're trying to push
as far as we can the peak of the
infection if it occurs out into the
period of the year when the NHS is
better able to do things because the
other infectious diseases of winter are
not there so that is one of the key
principles of the delay strategy it's
pushing out into the late spring and
summer period now when when we get there
there are basically there are three
separate sets of things that we are
going to need to do the first of which
is to take measures or consider measures
which are going to reduce the peak of
the infection so the proportion of
people infected to get at the same time
is smaller and these are the kinds of
decisions around social distancing and
other areas which will need to have
presented ministers with a menu which
have been looked at scientifically
modeled out what is the combination of
things that can pull down the peak that
will make the difference between what
the NHS normally can do and this peak as
small as possible that's the first thing
the second thing we can do and must do
is to isolate from the virus but not
from society and with this is how we do
this is a key thing or older people and
people who are vulnerable for other
reasons that is both very good for their
health and it also will reduce the
pressure on the NHS and then the third
thing will be to reconfigure the
services to deal with the peak which
will be a relatively short one in the
sense of it is a number of weeks so we
will see this coming from the modelling
and what we will try and do is in a
sense be prepared to slow down or
postpone anything that is postponed
about and then deal with the peak that
we deal with that we find ourselves with
at the point it arrives and you know as
a doctor myself especially is also a
doctor this is normal medical practice
is to actually basically you you adjust
what you do clinically to the particular
group of problems you've got in front of
us and that's what the NHS will do as
any group of doctors would do any group
of nurses would do thanks very much Joe
Murphy Evening Standard
no filing body typically run Dave Mirra
career from the mirror couple questions
to different people if I'm a CMO in the
CSR just wondering what specific advice
you might have for care people in care
homes because obviously they're both
elderly and vulnerable whether that
would affect visitors perhaps or whether
they you would suggest that individuals
should stay within the care homes and
for Prime Minister can you give seni
more detail on the on the local
resilience plans that you've got in
place the document talks about
government's in the day of the UK and
the different developed administration's
dealing with councils to help with
things for example talking about an
increase in deaths arising from the
outbreak we've all heard sort of scare
stories horror stories about morgues in
Hyde Park and so on can you give us some
reassurance about what plans were in
place to make sure that if people what
people do die is handled with dignity
sure so just quickly on that one pepper
obviously there are long-established
plans when we're working with local
resilience forms to make sure that
everybody gets dignity that they deserve
and there are long long established
plans to make sure that like and
specifically we will give some very
specific advice on care homes but one of
the things we're keen to avoid this is
going back to Patrick's point at the
beginning is doing things too early
because if you do them early you get no
benefit from the epidemic but what you
do get is a social cost so what we want
to do is give the advice at the point we
think it's going to have an effect on
improving the lives or reducing the
chance of infection of people in their
scope of care homes and at that point we
will give specific care home advice
thanks Kate Ferguson sun-hi prime
minister what words are you sure what
words of reassurance do you have for
grips sitting at home worried about what
this means for them that they can get
through this crisis and that Britain can
get through this crisis well thanks okay
I just want to really to repeat what I
said at the outset there are some some
very simple things that we can do to
protect ourselves and to and to stop the
spread of the disease number one
wash your wash your hands I don't repeat
how to wash your hands but the second
thing is is really just to repeat what
the the CMO and the chief scientific
adviser have have told us this is
overwhelmingly a disease that is
moderate in its effects people recover
speedily and well from it that's what
we're seeing the overwhelming majority
of cases and I have no doubt at all that
with the scientific advice that we have
with the levels of preparedness that we
have with our fantastic NHS our ability
to test and to survey the spread of the
disease of this country is going to get
through our coronavirus no doubt at all
and get through it in in good shape but
there are things to do now which have
been clear and and the other things we
will give advice on as they come at the
right time and want to re-emphasize this
point you do things at the wrong time
you end up with an awful lot of
disruption and you potentially make them
less effective when they come in because
people stop doing them by that stage
because they can't see the point correct
[Music]
well the day's Alma is now engaging with
business of all kinds to ensure that
they understand what you know the the
reasonable worst case scenario is that
you you describe them of course making
the necessary preparations to ensure
that they have the the protections that
they need but I don't want to go into
more details of this stage because as I
think we're trying to make clear this
morning we're taking each step as it as
it comes Jason thank you Jason goes from
the Daily Mail it sounds like you're
bracing people for some potentially big
sacrifices here covering for people at
work for extended periods suspending
their social lives maybe being
quarantined at home almost a kind of
wartime effort I mean do you think we
still have you're a student of these
things do we still have that sort of
Bulldog spirit to fight this on the
beaches as it were and well I've got you
can I congratulate you on your impending
fatherhood and asks whether your plan to
set an example to new fathers by taking
paternity leave right substantive point
Jason basis of data by tools I do think
that this is a national challenge and I
do think that we will we are faced with
something that could be but the
potential is there for this to be
something that our country has to to get
through but I've got abs in Oh doubt
that we have the
the resources you've got be the health
service we've got the expertise to do
I'm very confident the British public
understand that I think a brief public
have can see exactly what the balance of
risk is I think they can see because I
think we're getting some very very clear
advice I think they're getting a very
clear picture of how we all need to
behave and I think we'll get through it
as I say in very good shape and on your
second question I think the answer is
almost certainly yes from HuffPost Prime
Minister what advice have you got for
parents who think that their children
may well be suffering from school
closures this summer in a few weeks time
and you'd and we're not or both of your
advisers want to give a bit more
explanation on that yes well I mean or
on school closures we don't think that
schools should be closing in principal
we think if all schools should stay open
but that school authorities should
follow the advice of of public health
England that's what that's that's where
we are and I think there are probably
two things to say in addition to that
the first is that there are no there's
no evidence at the moment that children
are particularly badly affected by this
virus in quite in fact quite the other
way currently the evidence from China at
least would imply that children have
much less of this disease that's either
because they're getting it less often or
that they are getting it but it is much
milder so the first reason to close
schools which is this is particularly
dangerous for children which some
infections are would not be a sensible
reason in this case the second reason is
that in some identities useful to
actually close schools as a way of
damping down the epidemic significantly
and one of the things that Patrick with
the scientific advisory group and
experts is doing he's modeling out would
that help sufficiently in this
particular epidemic if it were to be
done as a way of pulling down the peak
of the infection to justify the
considerable the
including I have to say to the NHS which
would start to lose health care workers
who had to look after children at home
so these things are difficult balancing
acts and the scientific advisory group
are working through this so Patrick
might wish to add a bit had there that
intending to do this so we're modeling
what the impact of school closures might
be and of course it's wrong to do that
in isolation so there are several
measures you could take to try and limit
this and other countries have taken
various measures and the school closures
needs to be part of that so there's no
point looking at it in isolation and
saying just do that we know that's not
effective or not very effective it has
to be done as part of other things and
when you put the other things together
actually where school closures fit in
that compared to the disruption and so
on and given that children aren't
affected maybe rather lower down than
you might expect
so we're modeling that at the moment and
we will come up with advice around which
the interventions are that make the most
impact which combinations make the most
impact and what the potential societal
disruption associated with that is in
order that ministers and the Prime
Minister could make decisions around
those that's very I think you are Chris
Smith of times yes I think you approach
when you're considering some of these
more drastic measures whether it's
school closures restricting gatherings
other things you'll have onto these
powers that you're planning to introduce
you may be guided by scientific terms so
this is fundamentally a political choice
the 2011 pandemic plan was much more
less a fair saying no reason to cancel
mass gatherings that's now shifted
commuters about how you personally will
make those judgments more principals you
be guarded by making the trade off
between disruption and mitigating well
it's not going going to surprise you
Chris if I say that the principle that
we will guide us in all these decisions
is the scientific advice when it comes
to calculating the the trade-off that
you identify between ethic acity and
disruption it's it's the science that
will help us to take the decision
cor Sherwood from from LBC I think
you're going over the LBC that good okay
Thank You Prime Minister
thank entus LBC and prime minister in
the document published today
mentions that plans are in place for
what it causes severe prolonged pandemic
as experienced in 1918 with Spanish flu
how seriously is the government taking
that prospect and how likely is it to
get that back well thank you thank you
very much I think probably on the on the
sort of statistical possibilities of
that of a 1918 style epidemic I probably
looked to past as Patrick so the first
thing say this looks very different from
1918 pandemic in that 1918 affected lots
of children and young people and this
largely in terms of serious illness and
death effects elderly people and people
with pre-existing diseases so it looks
very different in terms of that in terms
of the scale as we've said at the moment
we've got a reasonable worst-case
scenario we think for all the reasons
that I laid out earlier on about when
you see what's happening with Han
actually the scale is less than that and
it looks like the numbers should come
down in terms of the percentage of the
population affected and it may alter the
perception of the mortality rate as well
so that the reasonable worst-case
scenario is based on pandemic flu and
the data that we now get in the
information we get is suggesting that
actually those numbers can be modified
there are some differences it last
slightly longer so there are some there
are some changes what we think in terms
of the profile of an epidemic and this
may change that you get numbers from
Europe and the UK is that you can think
of it as roughly two to three months
from an outbreak of of sustaining
person-to-person transmission 2 to 3
months up to the peak and 2 to 3 months
after the peak to decline again is the
timeline that we'd be thinking of may
the hall Express
if people think they have this illness
they have to self quarantine they're
going to need to need food what
practical advice can you give about
people keeping their larders and fridge
is stocked without triggering panic
buying well I mean I can tell you we've
looked we have a behavioral subgroup of
the sage that we talked about and the
first thing to say is I think the advice
from the paper scientist actually people
don't panic they take what they seems
like logical decisions based on what
they believe and the advice the moment
is absolutely no reason to be doing any
panic buying of any sort or going out in
sand and keeping large supplies of
things clearly there will need to be
measures in cases of household
quarantine for making sure that food is
in the right place at the right time but
we imagine that that could be a rolling
case of household quarantine if that
measure becomes necessary and clearly
there will need to be in things in place
for care homes and so on at that point
if that decision is made and obviously
what this goes back to the point Chris
made earlier on if you take the issue of
looking after the vulnerable and having
issues of social distancing there what
you don't want to do is end up with a
position where people truly become
socially isolated in the wrong way and
you definitely do not want situations
where people are afraid to come to their
front door
fear of catching something so that will
need to be measures pursue play if those
things become necessary I think the
other thing which is very clear from the
behavioral science is that the response
of and this is a scientific quite not a
general point is that the response of
the British public to disasters and
emergencies is extraordinary outbreaks
of altruism and that is actually a
likely response all that is absolutely
absolutely true yes please sorry Thank
You Jay Merrick from the IEEE newspaper
excuse me given that they are in
high-risk groups the elderly and the ill
are likely to feel quite frightened
today and may not be reassured by the 1%
rate and by hand-washing what can you
say to them to feel slightly less
frightened about this well thanks Jane
I'm obviously
just repeat what Patrick and Chris have
already said about prioritizing the the
needs of the of the vulnerable and and
the elderly but on your on your
statistical concerns perhaps yes Chris I
think the thing to be really clear about
is even for the highest risk group the
great majority people will survive this
so if you look at the Chinese data if
you take the very oldest people the
great majority survived so it is
important to stress that and if you're
talking about the low risk groups the
rate of mortality is well below 1% so I
think there's always a danger people
think this is actually got a higher risk
than it actually has for them personally
and I think second thing to say is
clearly the point of the NHS is approach
to this is going to be to prioritize
those who are in greatest need of
treatment and that is the way the NHS
will respond to this at all stages of
this epidemic which will have a
beginning a middle and an end and we
will just respond slightly differently
in those three phases thank you very
much thank you it's Emily Ashton at
BuzzFeed and I just wanted to ask about
holidays there will be lots of people
out there who've books spring and summer
holidays not just far afield but to
Europe and they're really looking
forward to it should they be preparing
to cancel those holidays and staying in
the UK or do you think those holidays
can still go ahead a lot depends on on
on where the outbreaks are so at the
moment the outbreaks are across Europe
and across most of the world in some
form or another and they're contained in
many places but are becoming uncontained
in some places and so again it depends
on the stage because once the epidemic
is everywhere then actually restricting
travel that that makes no difference at
all and at the moment we're certainly
not recommending any change to behaviors
in relation to that and as it grows and
if it grows in the UK then of course it
doesn't really make any sense to say
that you're more risk somewhere else
than you are here so is that one point
on that because it is a very important
point
the first reason for people coming
advice on travel is to do with
it actually going to transmit the virus
around and by the later stage it simply
isn't because it'll be everywhere so it
makes no difference the second stage and
this is only relevant to a few places is
if you happen to be in a place with a
very weak health service at the peak of
their epidemic we here than the NHS that
obviously might be more problematic and
this is particularly an issue for people
who are older or have pre-existing
health conditions so I think in those
situations they just might want to think
through the practicalities of being in a
place where these which has a health
service less strong than NHS but that
isn't a point about removing the virus
around it's simply a practical point yes
thank you premises Kevin's Caulfield
from politics home we understand that
the health secretary has spoken to
social media companies and about
potentially posting fake news about the
corona virus what would be your message
to like sir to my certain Facebook who
maybe are living these types of reports
that it's it's exactly what the mat
would say you know we we've all got to
be very responsible and you know the
media has a very important role in this
particularly the the social media net
electronic media of all types and I'm
sure that they will they will want to
convey the the right messages and convey
the right the right balance of risk and
there are lots of questions over here
yes yes Victoria Victoria McDonald from
Channel 4 News
there's been a bit of confusing advice
about things like shaking hands yes and
I'm intrigued to know whether you've
developed a personal policy yourself so
next time there's a visiting dignitary
and you're standing on the doorsteps of
darling streets are you gonna shake
their hands and if not how are you gonna
Verta an international incident no well
I will reach what I can tell you that I
I'm shaking hands contusions at her I
was at a hospital the other night where
I think there were a few there are
actually a few coronavirus patients and
I shook hands with everybody you'll be
pleased to know and I continue to shake
hands and
I think it's very important that we you
know people obviously can make up their
own mind I think the matter said that
people must make up their own minds but
I think the scientific evidence is to
the experts our judgement is wash
washing your hands is the crucial thing
before you shake hands
hi I'm Ashley furlong from Politico is
the health secretary meeting with EU
health ministers to discuss the
situation if so what sort of
coordination is being discussed and and
secondly could you confirm that the UK
will not seek continued access to the
EU's early warning system for for for
situations such as these in the future
well thanks we continue to have a global
coordination that you would expect and I
you know I congratulate the the Chinese
authorities actually on the speed with
which they posted the the news if you
look at the speed with which they posted
the news of an outbreak that has had
serious international implications and
I'm getting I'm getting this the signal
from the back that that I'm going to
take two more questions and then if
that's okay we're gonna were three more
questions one two and then you over
there yes Thank You Prime Minister it's
Kate Proctor from the Guardian and the
advice and the suggestion that cities
could potentially be locked down to try
and contain this is that advice now no
longer a likely course of action and
secondly I wanted to be very clear from
the chief medical officer the mortality
rate of 1% you did suggest it would be
higher for the elderly could you tell us
what that figure is I think you should
probably answer play the honours on the
lockdown necessity on a mobile mortality
yes so the the health secretary has been
really clear that there are multiple
options that can be looked at ranging
from ones which have huge effects or
large effects and very small
implications for individuals washing the
hands being absolutely top of the range
through to ones that may have very big
social effects and much less
implications and what we presented to
ministers as patrick said is a
combination of those modelled out
scientifically
to work out what are the right things to
do in general though and I don't to take
any clear thing off the table because
it's important that one thinks it's
through the locking down a city is most
useful when it is starting in one place
with a high transmission in that place
and nowhere else and it seems unlikely
we'll be in that situation in in the
medium to long term future but it's
important that of course all the options
are available to people what was the
second around the one to one percent so
I think that and the the Chinese
authorities are very helpfully laid that
out and in fact The Times newspaper did
a nice graphic showing the Chinese data
this morning the thing there it's the
first thing to say is there are some
questions about exactly how you
calculate mortality and I don't want to
go into that's a pretty technical area
on this but I think what is clear is
that there is a significant ramp up in
the risk of people dying with this
infection once they get over eighty it
begins to take off a bit earlier than
that but the exact percentages will
depend on a lot of factors including the
health care system you have in place so
I would not expect and I don't think
Patrick would expect the numbers were
seeing in China
automatically to read over to the UK and
I think what we'll get is more data
probably from European systems which
would be more comfortable to our own
fairly soon and we're very happy to
update things once we have those thanks
very much yes Prime Minister David
Hughes from PA we know that you're
considering the emergency powers
wondered could you give us a sense of
what kind of powers you are considering
and given the age of veterans and the
wartime generation will VE Day
commemorations have to now be scaled
back okay well just thanks on the second
point about specific events you know
we're still as I say in the in the
contain and research stage of this we
haven't taken decisions on specific
events as as we've been we've been
discussing
just now and on the powers issued very
very important for everybody to
understand that yes it is necessary to
have some legislation in respect of
things like school operation borders
quarantine but these are exceptional and
short-term and they're not intended to
last beyond the the the outbreak I think
the last question yes Thank You Laura
making issue it from forces knees and it
says in the document that the Ministry
of Defense has put in place plans to
ensure delivery of its key operations in
the UK and overseas are you able to
expand on what those operations are and
what the risks might be if you've had to
ensure they can be delivered Laura
laughs I'm not going to expand now only
on what those operations are but I can
tell you that in so far as is possible
the the mo D that our armed services are
police and all our public services will
be going about their business in the
normal in the normal way and I just want
to bring this to a close if I can just
by recapitulating the the four
essentials of this of this plan its
contain delay research and then if
necessary mitigate I hope it's been
useful
I want to thank particularly the the
chief medical officer Chris and our
chief scientific officer scientific
adviser Patrick for I think what has
been a very very clear presentation of
the assessment of the risk and the steps
that the government proposes to take if
that risks if those risks should
transpire thank you all very much for
answering thank you